so for those that didn't see my previous
YouTube video I got absolutely destroyed
by this adorable lookingkin and now it's
time for Revenge so
I haven't reached the point where I feel
obligated to cheat
so I'm not gonna have any assistance
random colors
okay I'm white it's the last time I
played London and I just it crushed my
London I was losing probably within 20
moves
so I'm gonna play E4
and
I'm not going to listen to all the
psychological trash talk
that it does or the meow talk oh let's
play ponziani okay
ponziani against mittens
D5 is a main line but um this is a
tricky variation
yeah F6 Bishop to B5
and it's been a while since I've looked
at this one
take
let's see if she knows the theory yeah
so this this E4 move is playable but
then C4
and the main thing I remember is Queen
C5 and then or wait
no Queen D6 and then C5
yeah this is some like very obscure
opening prep and then D4
and if ampa Swan I play Bishop E3
if that move I have to start thinking
I wonder if I can play this
D5 unleashing the queen
that looks risky though
I've also play this Knight D2 F5 Knight
C4
I think this is a little bit more
rational
I'm hitting the pawn too
measure of F5
okay Knight C4
wait Knight C4 is just going to grab the
pawn
but then it feels like there's
compensation
Queen B4 would hang a queen
D7 okay
um
Knight C3
I actually like this position I feel
like it's not so bad I'm on the prep but
um
just uh the attacking potential
especially on the queen side like if I
cover castles
probably not gonna happen
yeah this Pawn is pinned so
can I start with D5
D5 takes and then Rook D1 it's getting
really Tactical
wow
D5 takes
and there's really not too many options
because
I think black is threatening to move the
Rook
there's a line D5 takes takes takes in
the 93.
I don't know
I haven't limited time I could just go
in the tank
D5 take take take the problem is I don't
see a clear follow-up
after Queen digs D5
oh maybe I have Rook D1
Rook D1 if takes I just take back the
Queen's still hit
okay let's try this
at least there's a couple options
yeah so Rook D1 I originally rejected
this move because takes but
I don't have to take the queen
take this way
and Bishop D6 Bishop F4
how many pawns am I down I'm down two
Pawns
and where's my compensation
I'll start with Rook D1
yeah
I mean taking looks attractive but after
it takes
I have two things hanging
really
really
allowing me to take the Rook with Chuck
I am a tiger
I feel like that's a lie I feel like
you're just stockfish
take take I'm up the exchange
what is it saying
the light that burns twice as bright
Burns half as long
really it's just confusing me with
poetry
I have to say focus on the position
uh
okay your queen is gone too oh no both
are Queens
93 night D5
I feel like I've I've already tricked
mins with the ponziani
yeah
I'm
am I a material
I guess it's technically equal material
okay Rook
for Bishop and duponts
uh there's not too many options for the
knights
93 is the most logical
like A3 is actually interesting hitting
this Pawn
uh maybe inducing B4
wait Knight A3
93 1997 is weird
[Music]
I'm actually leaning towards Knight A3
because black has to take some measures
to not lose his Pawn the B4 Knight B5
looks attractive
on the surface it looks really ugly but
okay and I don't mind the trade
so it's off the color Bishop situation
um Rook B8
or a rook B1
and then 97
. this should be okay
97 Bishop C5
I feel like I have chances this game F3
takes takes takes Rook D7
I don't want to screw it up
not three
men's has gone silent
yeah Rook D7
you're not a tiger you're just a fish
a very powerful fish
wait I have this move and then King G1
I feel like it's playing much weaker
than it played against me yesterday
but I have to still be like really
really careful
because the position is so imbalanced
and I have options here I can take on B5
or take on C7
[Music]
or play King F2
King F2 Bishop G4
the thing about King F2 I'm not
threatening to take the bishop but I'm
threatening to play this
that's actually a pretty big threat
also I'm I'm not looking at chat I have
alerts muted this is this is serious
chess
yeah I feel like Rook 8 is going to be
some really annoying counter-attack
or C7 rookate
yeah move the bishop and then it's
already Rook G2 ideas
so king of two probably makes sense on
more levels
okay I don't want to lose I feel like
Rook C7
and King F2 will actually just transpose
but King F2 maybe keeps more options
open
I'll start with King F2
yeah so now Rook C7 but I have the
option of Rook G1 as well
which I don't think does much King D5
okay let's go ahead and take
this is so scary
really
if I check
I just wants to win a two
wait what if I take here
hitting the bishop yet again
I'm paranoid that I'm overlooking
something
there's there is a bishop C4 but then
they take on B7
I'm so paranoid about everything here
though
but let's go for it
okay if I take
oh
I see the points takes takes takes
Bishop D5
I think it's a losing Rook ending
don't hurt me men's
wait I can take and then take on G7 and
take on H7
wait this is fascinating
let's go for this
ah
It Feels So Close to a draw
I take Bishop D5
I have like some Rook B3
no
if I take on I mean taking on G7
actually looks
practically like a
my best option
I have a bad feeling about it though
maybe I I can start with like Rook B2
okay let's start by taking because the
Knight can't be taken it's just losing I
think
okay
that's such an engine move not taking
either Pawn
just trains her
suffocate my king
I do have this move though but then Rook
C3
I mean at this point I think I'm playing
for a draw
do I have this move
I just run the king towards the center
this is so complex though
King E3 take King D4
Rook D3 King C5
I like the prospect of having two
outside passwords the problem is I'm
losing E2 in a lot of lines
like Rook H5
King F4 check
oh there is a trick okay Rook H4 King
Rook H5
King G4
I was thinking I could trick it into
like trading off everything the trick
was this line Knight G4 take take and
then Rook here
I think would force a draw
so Rook H5
uh how do I do this
reach 5 king G4 maybe Rook H6
I gotta try it
starting with the check
yeah
now if I could sack the rook and then
defend the the end game
wait do I have takes and Rook before
is it giving me a draw
wait a minute
rookie five it's the same idea
as the other line rookie 5 Rook B4
no there's Rook C3
oh it's so close
by Rook C3
yeah it's losing for me
Oh I Feel So Close
so if I play this
I think rookie I mean there's not too
many options here
Arc H6
so I'm putting the Rook uh on the
potential for working square but the
king's in the way
such an engine move
I I still feel like a draw is within
grasp
Rook B4
via's just toying with me maybe it's
like treating me as a cat toy
and I'm just getting like pushed around
by its paws
Rook G7
King F5 Rook H5 the king Retreats I mean
this this position is so complex
I also can start with
maybe we'll start with each three
ensuring G4 is under control
and then I go after the F Pawn doesn't
look promising though
so annoying I can't play Rook B2 because
of the fork
Ruchi seven
[Music]
Rook G7 King F5 King
I I need counter play counter play is
probably top priority
but not getting forked is also top
priority
okay let's start with this
because I'm going to have an additional
check
so I'll move the Rook to a better square
like Rook H5
I keep saying it's a tiger
what does that mean
maybe Rook C3 here or a rook G3
defending C3
knowing how Bots work if I can get an
equal position sometimes it will just
like give up and allow an easy draw
but even if it's slightly better it's
going to torture me
okay I have to accept the fact I'm
losing A2 and then I just have to hold
on to C3
I like the Rooks where they are like
they're
not vulnerable
don't meet me
I don't think I'm getting mated
yeah King D4
okay that's a good sign wait did it just
repeat
why is it going back every two moves
if I move back it's repetition
knowing how stockfish works I don't
think it's going to repeat though but I
could play this
but that might allow Rook A4
I'll be really careful with how I do
this
all right rookie three Rook A4
King C5 Rook C4 King
B5
I think I'll just move back to E3
if it repeated once it might repeat
three times
King E3
yeah let's uh let's play King E3 let's
see if it repeats
oh
if it plays 95 I claim the draw
okay it's trying to torture me
so what is this
Rook A4
I mean it looks like I can take the
bishop the problem is 95.
95 King C5 Rook A5 King C6 Rook takes
Bishop a rook takes Rook
um
I feel like King C5 is a way to go but
then it's basically tricking me into the
line I didn't want to go into
but there's not really a great way to
avoid this
and maybe The Rook can
go so there's more potential checks
I think I should play this because it
makes way for the pawn as well
and the rook's not vulnerable in HH
it feels so wrong because I mean The
Bishop's attacked
maybe I start with this but then 95.
then I guess we transpose
so it's a a choice between this
and this
I don't think it makes a difference I
think the lines just transpose
um I mean let's start
King C5
does make a difference
start with King C5
and limit the discoveries
oh maybe it did make a difference
wait after this
oh it's running Rook A5 it's so sneaky
okay
if I play like Rook h8
I mean this was my original plan anyway
The Rook is tied down too
I mean the problem is
if I play King B5
immediately there's uh or there's Rook
A5
but for example Rook h8 F5 King B5
then it's okay
let's go for this
you have triumphed an existing for
longer than many before you hey I've
survived 41 moves
the two games I played priorit defeated
me in in 30 game moves in both games
okay I think it's time to push
I mean I have to allow wait a minute
it's about to like Checkmate me in some
Twisted way Rooks he's four
King B6 Rook C6
I think I have to go for H4
I'm trying to imagine the scenario where
I got mated but
and
my work's gonna be covering the
the rink
okay I can go back to the center oh if I
go back to the center this might have
five I go back this way
wait a minute go back this way
am I already losing
am I dead with whichever way I go rugby
five King here Knight here
King here I might have to like go into
the corner
I think this is even worse check
here
I think I should run this way
what's the dark Square corner
I have this move but then there's this
move
if I play this move Knight C4 King here
it's so close to checkmating me
we have this move
check there
I don't see the mate though
but I'm terrified
if I play here then like some I think
Rook B2 and then I can't stop Bishop C2
so I have to try this
okay
don't hurt me
Rook A3 really
if I play this oh the bishop controls
age I have this move though
it just wants to play this
I have to go for this
this is ridiculous
I I can't I can't stop Rook A3 without
losing material
I can't even set up a stalemate trap
oh let's play this
wait a minute Chuck
King D3
ah wait King D3
because I win the F Pawn
if I can win the F Pawn
then there's still hope
start by pushing
now this is still interesting actually
let's check and then here
um
I mean a low depth engine is known to
like sometimes spoil end games
wait a minute
check here
check
it's just gonna go for meat
this is so frustrating
let's try this
preparing Rook G7
and then check
I think I check again
but King C2 is coming
what about this
ah
I think I'm dead
unless there's some
in this move
I think this is the best chance
yeah I just wants to destroy me
it's even it probably it should say oh
no my knight
but uh yeah if I take the night that's I
get needed so I have to play this
oh no
yeah it's playing like stockfish
I'm dead
what to do
let's let's see how long I can survive
I was gonna finish me off oh I can't
survive much longer I should look like
King B2
oh no my king
oh I felt like I I had chances that game
I I feel like I tricked it with a
ponziani and it's still be me
all right GG
uh maybe this was another video for
what is turning into a YouTube series
taking on min's
men's is uh as merciless
I should do some post-game analysis too
uh
I made two blunders
see let's see if this loads
I just want to yeah I just want to see
the evaluation at various points
um
hopefully people can see this
so the the opening was all preparation
like castling
turn on the eval bar too
um
the engine will say white is a little
bit worse but
I think I managed to salvage things
Queen takes E5 D4
Queen G6 Knight fd2 Bishop F5
oh I was better I was much better after
an AC4 wow
so I did trick it
in this ponziani line
bio okay of course didn't play perfectly
engine wants Knight E3 here
I found D5 yeah it takes Rook T1
we traded
so I I somehow equalized
but as white
Knight A3 is playable
so I wasn't worse
but it still outplayed me
F3
F3 was playable
Rook D7
yeah this position like
because black has their two minor pieces
of
it's
it's not easy for light like it seemed
like I'm winning a lot of Pawns in
various lines but rookie it is so strong
um but I was still okay like
it's not a decisive Advantage for black
engine says Rook C5
not easy to find
yeah I miss this idea I think Rook C6 is
just losing
maybe I could have gone for this without
her
slightly better practical chances
but I took on G7
I'm really curious about the moment it
repeated
[Music]
man I'll play me so cleanly though
Knight C4 King D4 and I went back
and I repeat the second time
[Music]
and I it knew not to repeat three times
yeah
I feel like a cat toy
King C5
is this was a good game though I don't
think there were any like super obvious
blunders
and I had my chances out of the opening
if this goes on YouTube
uh let me know in the comments if you
want to see more men's content
um I'm trying to do my best against his
but
it's a very strong v-line
yeah it looks like looks like mins
played too strong for game review to
handle
what to do